among the many changes director zack
snyder made to his cut of justice league
he gave a larger role to amber heard who
plays the atlantean princess
mira her character gets a bit more
developed in the four-hour film with a
battle against steppenwolf and a role in
the nightmare ending that implies
aquaman
is no longer among the living i'll stab
this through his heart for what he did
arthur
heard was reportedly one of the few
actors to be called in to do reshoots
when the snyder cut was in production
after completing those reshoots heard
told comicbook.com
i'm super excited about it we just
wrapped on reshoots and i just
love nerds i love nerds excuse my
language
she explained that nerds are often
connected to great projects and that
nerd passion drives people to want to be
part of something
however following the release of the
movie on hbo max she revealed something
else that
cool atlantean costume she wore
basically makes no sense
in an amusing instagram video uploaded
on march 31st
heard appears to be in her trailer
wearing her full body costume complete
with the headpiece
though it's not clear whether it's from
shooting for the original film or
reshoots for the snyder cut
rather than imbuing her with any special
powers though the costume appears to be
hampering her mobility
heard apparently can't sit down in her
costume nor can she do much else
as she tries to hoist herself to a
standing position the actress knocks
over a cup the contents of which form a
green pool on the floor
although she gamely tries to grab it off
the floor she can't bend over far enough
to reach it
generally it seems that the bodysuit in
question has very little give to it
making it impossible for her to use her
knees and also making it difficult for
her to bend at the waist she tries some
twists but nothing seems to work
particularly well
heard sardonically captioned the image
she's beauty and she's grace
fortunately none of this really shows up
in the movie it's a good thing she's
just standing still in some of her
dialogue scenes with aquaman
the movie creates an illusion that this
outfit is pliant and elastic enough for
her to fight alien invaders in it
underwater mind you and comfortable
enough for a long trek in a
post-apocalyptic wasteland
but in reality the costume is clearly
more about making mira look cool than
letting her be functional in any way
there has been a long history of
criticism against how women are often
outfitted in superhero media
as activist holly jacobs pointed out in
the twitter thread that followed her
post of her video there practicality is
never a priority in outfitting women in
the media industry
with most costumes though the problem is
less about inability to move and more
about skimpiness
one oft shared twitter post from the
time of the original film's release in
2017
compared the costumes worn by the
amazons and designed by lindy heming for
the patty jenkins-directed wonder woman
complete with breastplate armor
and the leathery midriff-baring amazon
costumes from 2017's justice league as
designed by michael wilkinson
heard's justice league costume overall
is better than many while form fitting
it is a full-on regal ensemble befitting
her station and her role in atlantean
culture
complete with a crown shoulder pad armor
gauntlets leg and knee armor and
carvings that suggest
accents of course you could argue that
the armor focuses on her chest in
unnecessary ways but it's not as
revealing as the costumes many other
women have had to wear in superhero
movies
wear your clothes put some clothes on
and hurt's comparative modesty comes in
contrast to jason mamoa's general look
as aquaman in the film which basically
seems to involve
jeans and shirts he's constantly taking
off to reveal his bare chest
though later in the movie he also gets a
costume upgrade so in some ways the
costume deftly avoids some of the usual
criticism
while as observed by cbr it stays true
to the version the character
wears to war in the comic books if only
she could move in it she'd be a
superhero to be reckoned with
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dc films are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single
one